no son seguros tampoco.
Así que este mundo en el que vivimos,
este mundo en el que cada conversación
tiene el potencial de derivar en una discusión
donde los políticos no pueden hablarse entre sí
y donde incluso el más trivial de los temas tiene
a uno debatiendo intensamente en pro y a otro en contra. Eso no es normal.
Pew Research hizo un estudio de 10 000 adultos de EE.UU.
y descubrió que hoy, estamos más polarizados,
estamos más divididos
que nunca en la historia.
Somos menos propensos a conectar,
lo que significa que no escuchamos al resto.
Y, tomamos decisiones sobre dónde vivir,
con quién vivir e incluso quiénes serán nuestros amigos,
con base en lo que ya creemos.
Una vez más, eso significa que no escuchamos al resto.
Una conversación requiere un equilibrio entre hablar y escuchar,
y en algún lugar del camino, perdimos ese equilibrio.
Ahora, en parte se debe a la tecnología.
A los móviles que todos tienen ya sea en sus manos
o lo bastante cerca para usarlos rápidamente.
Según Pew Research,
cerca de 1/3 de jóvenes en EE.UU. envían más de 100 SMS al día.
Y muchos de ellos, en su mayoría, son para escribir a sus amigos
que para conversar personalmente.
Hay un gran artículo en The Atlantic.
escrito por el profesor de secundaria, Paul Barnwell.
Él asignó a sus niños una tarea de lenguaje.
Quería enseñarles a hablar sobre un tema específico sin usar notas.
Y dijo esto: "Me di cuenta de que..."
(Risas)
"Me di cuenta de que la competencia verbal
puede ser la única capacidad más ignorada que fracasamos en enseñar.
Los chicos pasan horas relacionándose entre sí con ideas a través de pantallas,
pero raramente tienen una oportunidad
para afinar habilidades de comunicación interpersonal.
Puede sonar a pregunta tonta, pero tenemos que preguntarnos:
¿Hay alguna capacidad en el siglo XXI
más importante que poder sostener una conversación coherente y firme?".
Yo me gano la vida conversando con la gente:
ganadores del Premio Nobel, conductores,
multimillonarios, profesores de pre-escolar,
jefes de estado, plomeros.
Converso con gente que me agrada. Y con gente que no me agrada.
Converso a una profundidad personal con gente que estoy en desacuerdo
Pero aun así tengo una gran conversación con ellos.
Así que me gustaría pasar los próximos 10 minutos enseñándoles a conversar
y a escuchar.
Muchos ya han escuchado varios consejos sobre esto,
cosas como mirar a la gente a los ojos,
pensar en temas interesantes para discutir con anticipación,
mirar, asentir y sonreír para mostrar que prestan atención,
repetir justo lo escuchado o resumirlo.
Así que, quiero que olviden todo eso.
Es una estupidez.
(Risas)
No hay razón para aprender a mostrar que se presta atención
si de hecho se está prestando atención.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Ahora, yo uso las mismas capacidades como entrevistadora profesional
que las que uso en mi vida diaria.
Así que, les enseñaré cómo entrevistar a la gente,
y eso en realidad va a ayudarles a aprender a ser mejores conversando.
Aprender a tener una conversación
sin desperdiciar su tiempo, sin aburrirse,
y, ¡por Dios!, sin ofender a nadie.
Todos hemos tenido grandes conversaciones.
Las hemos tenido antes. Sabemos cómo son.
El tipo de conversación donde te marchas sintiéndote involucrado e inspirado,
o donde sientes que has hecho una conexión real
o has entendido perfectamente.
No hay razón
para que muchas de sus interacciones no puedan ser así.
Así que tengo 10 reglas. Y los guiaré a través de ellas.
pero honestamente, si solo eligen una de ellas y la dominan,
Uds. ya disfrutarán de mejores conversaciones.
Número uno: No sean multitareas.
Y no solo quiero decir que dejen su móvil,
su tablet, las llaves del auto o lo que tengan en las manos.
Quiero decir, estén presentes.
Estén en "ese" momento.
No piensen en la discusión que tuvieron con su jefe.
No piensen en lo que van a comer para cenar.
Si desean salir de la conversación,
abandonen la conversación,
pero no estén mitad presente y mitad ausente.
Número dos: No sean dogmáticos.
si quieren establecer su opinión
sin oportunidad a réplica, discusión, aportación o crecimiento,
escriban un blog.
(Risas)
Ahora, hay una buena razón por la que no permito sabiondos en mi show:
Porque son realmente aburridos.
Si son conservadores, odian a Obama, al programa de comida y al aborto.
Si son liberales, odiarán
a los bancos, las empresas las petroleras y a Dick Cheney.
Totalmente predecibles.
Y Uds. no querrán ser así.
Uds. deben iniciar una conversación suponiendo que tienen algo que aprender.
El afamado terapeuta M. Scott Peck dijo
que la escucha sincera requiere de ponerse uno mismo a un lado.
Y a veces eso significa dejar a un lado las opiniones personales.
Él dijo que al sentir esta aceptación,
quien habla estará cada vez menos vulnerable
y cada vez más dispuesto a abrir las represiones interiores
de su mente al que escucha.
Una vez más, supongan que tienen algo que aprender.
Bill Nye: "Cada persona que llegues a conocer, sabrá algo que tú no conoces".
Yo lo puse en este modo:
Todos son expertos en algo.
Número tres: Usen preguntas abiertas.
En este caso, observen a los periodistas.
Inicien preguntas con quién, qué, cuándo, dónde, por qué o cómo.
Si lo ponen en una pregunta complicada, van a obtener una respuesta simple.
Si les pregunto, "¿Se asustaron?".
Responderán a la palabra más enérgica en esa oración,
la cual es "asustarse", y la respuesta sería Sí o No me asusté.
"¿Estabas molesto?". "Sí, lo estaba".
Déjalos describirlo. Son los que saben.
Intenten preguntar cosas como, "¿Cómo fue eso?".
"¿Qué sintieron?".
Porque entonces puede que tengan que detenerse un tiempo y pensar en ello,
y van a tener una respuesta mucho más interesante.
Número cuatro: Sigan el ritmo.
Eso significa que vendrán pensamientos a su mente
y necesitan permitirles salir de su mente.
A menudo, hemos escuchado entrevistas
en la que un invitado está hablando por minutos
y luego el presentador vuelve y hace una pregunta
que parece haber salido de la nada, o que ya ha sido contestada.
Allí es probable que él haya dejado de escuchar hace 2 minutos
porque pensaba en esta pregunta realmente ingeniosa,
y estaba convencido y determinado a decirla.
Y nosotros hacemos exactamente lo mismo.
Estamos sentados conversando con alguien,
y recordamos la vez que encontramos a Hugh Jackman en una cafetería.
(Risas)
Y dejamos de escuchar.
Les vendrán historias e ideas.
Deben dejarlas venir y dejarlas ir.
Número cinco: Si no saben, digan que no lo saben.
Ahora, la gente en la radio, especialmente en NPR
es mucho más consciente de que está siendo grabada,
y es más prudente sobre los temas en lo que aseguran ser expertos
y sobre lo que afirman saber con seguridad.
Hagan eso. Pequen de precavidos.
La charla no debería ser común.
Número seis: No equiparen sus experiencias con las de ellos.
Si hablan sobre la perdida de un familiar,
no empiecen a hablar de la vez que perdieron un familiar.
Si hablan de problemas laborales,
no les cuenten cuánto odian su empleo.
No es lo mismo. Nunca es lo mismo.
Toda experiencia es individual.
Y, lo más importante, no es sobre Uds.
No necesitan usar ese momento para probar cuán sorprendente son
o cuánto han sufrido.
Una vez preguntaron a Stephen Hawking cuál era si CI, y él dijo:
"Ni idea. El que fanfarronea sobre su CI es un perdedor".
(Risas)
Las conversaciones no son una oportunidad promocional.
Número siete:
Procuren no ser repetitivos.
Es condescendiente, y es en verdad aburrido,
y tendemos a hacerlo mucho.
Especialmente en conversaciones de trabajo o con nuestros hijos.
Cuando tenemos una idea,
la seguimos parafraseando una y otra vez.
No hagan eso.
Número ocho: Eviten los detalles.
Francamente, la gente no está interesada
en los años, los nombres,
las fechas, todos esos detalles
que luchan por traer a su mente.
A ellos no les importan. Les importan Uds.
les importa cómo son,
qué tienen en común.
Así que, olviden los detalles. Déjenlos.
Número nueve:
esta no es la última, pero es la más importante.
Escuchen.
No puedo decirles cuántas personas importantes han dicho
que escuchar tal vez sea la capacidad más importante
que podrían desarrollar.
Buddha dijo, y estoy parafraseando,
"Si tu boca está abierta, no estás aprendiendo".
Y Calvin Coolidge dijo: "Nadie ha sido despedido por escuchar demasiado".
(Risas)
¿Por qué no escucharse mutuamente?
Número uno, nosotros preferimos hablar.
Cuando hablo, estoy en control.
No tengo que escuchar en lo que no esté interesado.
Soy el centro de atención.
Puedo reafirmar mi propia identidad.
Pero hay otra razón:
Que nos distraemos.
La persona promedio habla unas 225 palabras por minuto,
pero podemos escuchar hasta 500 palabras por minutos.
Así que nuestras mentes están llenando esas otras 275 palabras.
Y miren, sé que requiere esfuerzo y energía
realmente prestar atención a alguien,
pero si no pueden hacer eso, no están en una conversación.
solo son dos personas gritando oraciones apenas relacionadas
en el mismo lugar.
(Risas)
Tienen que escucharse el uno al otro.
Stephen Covey lo dijo muy bien.
Dijo: "Muchos de nosotros no escuchamos con la intención de entender.
Escuchamos con la intención de responder".
Una regla más, número diez, y es esta: Sean breves.
[Una buena charla es como una minifalda; corta como para captar interés,
pero lo suficientemente larga para cubrir el tema – mi hermana]
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Todo esto se reduce al mismo concepto básico, y es este:
Tengan interés en las personas.
Saben, yo crecí con un abuelo muy famoso,
y había un tipo de ritual en casa.
La gente venía a hablar con mis abuelos,
y cuando se iban, venía mi madre
y decía: ¿Saben quién era?
Era la segunda finalista a Miss America.
Él era el alcalde de Sacramento.
Ella ganó un Premio Pulitzer. Él es un bailarín de ballet ruso".
Y crecí suponiendo que
cada uno tiene algo sorprendente y oculto en sí.
Y creo que eso es lo que me hace una mejor conductora.
Conservo la boca cerrada tanto como pueda,
mantengo mi mente abierta,
y siempre estoy preparada para sorprenderme,
y nunca salgo desilusionada.
Uds. hagan lo mismo.
Salgan, conversen con la gente,
escuchen a la gente,
y, más importante, estén preparadas para sorprenderse.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)